here comes tim kennedy
into the studio hey man
what's going on man how you doing how
are you how are you man sit down take a
seat yeah yeah yeah welcome to the show
the new book is available today
scars and stripes and unapologetically
american story of fighting the taliban
ufc warriors and myself that's some
serious opponents yeah yeah the last
one's the dumbest for sure you think so
there's no doubt yourself you mean yeah
yeah that's the dumb one yeah i've done
a lot of dumb [ __ ] too and sometimes you
look back like why why do they do that i
don't know do you regret it or do you
like hey i'm happy i can write about it
um well i'm not happy i did it because i
could write about it i was uh
i was really happy about all the
failures and struggles and that's kind
of what the book is about
um you know my first wrestling
tournament i ever went to i got
obliterated
uh humiliated pinned in like a matter of
seconds at like
you know a little gymnasium in a podunk
town by a nobody wrestler and i just
look silly
um this is not the 2022 where everybody
got a participation trophy for you know
like everybody like the two guys didn't
get their hands raised like i stood
there like a loser my dad in this
gymnasium looking at me
and like that just like burned
so
like it was like acid through my soul
and those were the things that you know
if you talk to any of my coaches for
jackson winkle john any of my training
partners like this guy's
relentless in his training and it was
because of losing and having
had to feel the sting of of shame and
you know having jacare's hand be raised
as i stood there not called world
champion we went to afghanistan together
during the fall of afghanistan like peak
fall of afghanistan
we're on the we're on a plane like
recently yeah like in august yeah yeah
we were we were two of the 12 idiots
that were like middle-aged men you know
running around afghanistan evacuating
people were you evacuating like people
who had helped americans were there
america yeah yeah
i'm saying were they americans or like
just kind of guys who laughed
but this is like peak like this is
people trying to jump onto the outside
of airplanes
that time that's why they're they're
leaving and we're we're landing
wow yeah
wow what motivated like did you just
know that was happening let's go over
here somebody say you know i don't know
where again back to information where
people are getting curated information
and uh they're like man i don't think
the taliban the taliban's gonna be able
to take over afghanistan and all of us
are like bro
the moment you leave they will take that
base like the moment you even like
give them an inkling that you're going
to leave they're going to go take that
base and that's exactly what happened so
base by base inch by inch as american
forces started moving back into just
kabul
into
ultimately just became hikaya airport
that's the only place that american
forces were the rest of the country was
just overrun by taliban we knew that
immediately immediately yeah so we knew
that was going to happen and uh one of
our friends chattaroo show his former
translator aziz um was already getting
death threats of like hey we're gonna
kill you we're gonna actually we're not
gonna kill you we're gonna leave you
alive and we're gonna do terrible things
to your family especially your wife and
then we're gonna kill you and um and his
best friend had just been killed because
he's who his his uh contemporary that
had essentially had the same job had
just been hunted and killed and now they
were looking for aziz so we were two
founders uh four that stood up this
organization called save our allies
and we moved 12 000 people in 10 days
did you guys help from have help from
the government or did you guys kind of
have to go around
we had
like that's a really complex question
yeah it's a there's a lot i want to get
in trouble
i'll i'll answer it i'll i'll answer
that uh carefully okay um we have a
mutual friend that grew up with the
crown prince of uae
and um he we asked if we could launch
our operation from uae
and the the
government of uae said we're going to
give you one c-17 which is way more than
we expected
we thought we were going to be using
commercial planes and if you can get
anybody out safely we'll give you
another one oh and that that was their
mistake
so uh
they were only how many of you were
there so there's there's four guys on
the ground and it was a that's crazy and
there's a total of 12 people between uae
um washington dc and in afghanistan wow
how do you guys find people like if
there's somebody who's hiding from the
taliban or the word about being killed
how do you guys a know about them and b
know where to go and grab them and
coordinate who do you work for
these are no no there's literally trade
craft yeah there's a really clear
process this bone fides of us being like
a far recognition signal near
recognition signal then they have to
give us a whole bunch of digital
documents that then we confirm in person
and their name has to be
cross-referenced off a terrorist hit
list we have to make sure that they
actually have a department of state siv
you know p1 green card american
bunch of stuff yeah wild all the all the
things that we had to do before we put
somebody on a bus and then had to
smuggle and we had to sneak them on to
hki we had to get past the taliban
checkpoints and then we had to get them
onto hkaya base and then we had to get
them onto our ramp onto a plane and then
fly them out of that country then we
lily pad operation so we flew out of
afghanistan and we'd go to somewhere
else
qatar uae and then we would move them to
the final destination um just to like
paint the picture a hundred thousand
people were moved out during the fall of
afghanistan and we moved we have moved
17 000 of them as a non-profit so
there's 12 of you that's almost 20
percent yeah right total of like the
american government the australian
everybody on the planet
this organization
and there's really four of us now um and
uh
12 at the time yeah we got very very
efficient with what we were doing so day
one was 26 people
and uh the last day was just over 2 000.
and we thought we had a few more days
yeah we thought then the bombing
happened
and that changed everything is that when
you know we got to go yeah when we got
back when nick was saying that we didn't
uh um i've tried to kill him multiple
times now
we just got back from ukraine last week
yeah
wow yeah i know what you want is is that
what you're in are you trying to get
people out of ukraine are you just
trying to help them there
we don't need to talk about everything
it's like first okay
can we cuss on syria sure yeah [ __ ]
russia okay yeah and putin can [ __ ] off
okay so you're not on the side of putin
on this one no no okay
anti-communist here yeah
and turning cities into rubble and using
as civilians as hostages and and shields
it's uh
the the war crimes that they've the
atrocities that they've already
committed that you will never see the
light that will never see the light of
day that will never be talked about you
know like next door at fox or here on
sears um like
so
disgustingly deplorable that he should
burn in hell in like the darkest depths
of hell for forever are you surprised
too by the amount like because we
politicize everything in our country
like everything is my side or your side
the amount of people that are almost
just trashing ukraine and defending
putin you see it i'm surprised by the
amount of people in our public who is
actually somewhat siding with putin on
that especially in the beginning yeah
yeah
yeah i i don't understand why we
from masks to vaccines to
to russia to like it's always
divided yeah and it makes zero sense um
i don't think
i don't think it really is i think it's
the algorithms of social media that are
so divisive and like people are in echo
chambers and it feels like it's divided
but then when you actually just have
conversations with people
like
opposing political view type people and
you're like oh so we both don't like
putin because he's a murderer right come
on okay cool we're on the opposite side
of the aisle here i guess okay bump
knuckles
but then you'll talk to one person and
you're like oh you are twitter okay
nobody takes one person
no no it's biking
[Laughter]
[Music]
is it how does it is it
sad for you how do you feel when like
you see what's going on in the ukraine
right and you see it firsthand you see
how crazy it is and then you come over
and you're like wait
every nobody's talking about this
anymore because they're all talking
about johnny depp and amber hurst
for me the super frustrating thing is
you know we just spent a bunch of time
in ukraine you know quietly uh the team
that we have over there uh is made up
the leader of the team we have over
there is one of the guys that was with
us in afghanistan
absolute stud
one of the brightest humans on the
planet and there's maybe only a few
people on the planet can that can do
what he does and he is doing it in
multiple different theaters you know
hopping from afghanistan and then he
beat putin into ukraine
like he
knew what was going to happen and was
walking through the snow to make it into
ukraine through an illegal border
crossing wow like talk about gangster
yeah this dude is a freaking hero yeah
so
man
so we're out there
and you know we we're seeing what's
really happening and we're doing work to
bring
you know we've evacuated a number of
people uh to include you know the folks
that were that were killed or injured uh
from fox
and um
we're bringing logistics to places no
one else can bring logistics to bringing
whether it's food or fuel or whatever
and then we get home
and people are making comments on on his
social media or my social media
and we would correct them so that's
actually not what's happening and they
would just say you know oh you guys
don't understand or
or like you know it's not my social that
we were in ukraine it's not on his you
know right yeah and like you guys don't
know what you're talking about you know
he's like
cool yeah cool you've seen firsthand the
stupidity of people's reaction when they
think they know something you don't know
it's ridiculous
there is no shining armor in the story
you know the ukrainian government is
corrupt um zielinski is corrupt putin is
an evil terrorist and um his army as
communists that are conscripted don't
have a choice they'll be executed their
families will be murdered if they don't
do what he says um so there's there's
not like a knight in shining armor in
any of the story um but the true victim
like always are the people and the
people whose hosts homes are burnt and
turned to rubble um and that are caught
in the middle of this and and that's um
but but just playing a little devil's
advocate there though i mean i think
people could argue the same thing about
our government yeah you know i think you
i think you look at any
group of people in power and there's
corruption
you know but
we're not storming across the border
into canada and murdering people right
and just straight murdering like not
it's not a war it's
um
you know they're executing people on the
way out when they don't win yeah and by
design because they're women and
children trying to remove ukraine
um it's like in the ground they've
already take taken over they have
instituted
russian
curriculum already like not propaganda i
mean like ukraine no longer is a country
here's
russian
school books in all of the ground that
they've taken every one of the so it's
they're already by
a hitler type approach
you know the the storm across the border
kill everybody every kind of resistance
that you meet and then start instituting
this this
barrage of propaganda which just how how
effective is the propaganda like how
effective it is yeah yeah they've been
doing this a long time yeah
do you think that they are surprised
though they say it's not going the way
putin expected it to go and this is
exactly how they wanted it to go do you
think that he's not shocked by how long
this is taking or is that that's just
media saying that he's losing
oh he's not losing he's not no
no if if they don't get help uh it's a
foregone conclusion that they're they're
done what kind of help like military
like nato help yeah you know just think
about for a second the new russian
border is going to be finland
poland you know
the new russia goes all the way to
poland
think about that yeah like did you ever
think that that was what right that's
that's right now what do you think it is
too about like a government or whatever
they want to call it about like the
taliban like the stupidity of them as
the us is leaving to be doing things
like hunting uh these uh uh translators
and like already pulling girls out of
school like what like why don't you just
let the us leave and then do it i was
shocked by how fast they started being
dicks like like
what are we going to do
i don't know but it's just something
like bomb on yeah i already did that for
20 years just seemed like a bad strategy
like you figured they would just go all
right get out and then there's no cost
there's no consequence no they they
wanted us to see it
they did they wanted us to see it like
you just wasted all your time
so they were twisting the knife every
inch that we moved back wow and i mean
like the stories that we personally saw
yeah it was it was it was pretty awful
the roe the rules of engagement for the
military were that they could not go
outside the wire so they couldn't leave
unless there was an american in harm's
way
and so you know our team
had different rules because we basically
were there doing whatever we wanted so
you know tim was running outside the
wire
constantly
but um there were situations where
you know if the crowd got unruly they
would just dump an ak mag into the crowd
and just kill people and the u.s
government the military couldn't do
anything just had to stand there just
had to stand there and watch um
you know there was another situation
where you know a woman that uh you know
a group was was looking for
uh you know they were within arm's
length and the taliban just
got to her first just put her on the car
and shot her in the head on their car
like put the girl on the car looked at
them directly in the eyes and executed
this girl and was like there's nothing
you can do about it this is my
afghanistan what is the motive
behind giving the military that type of
a directive saying you have to just
stand here and watch this
there was a period of time where it went
when it's a military operation you can
you can go out and create a perimeter
and you can do it whatever you know you
need the operation is called a neo
non-combatant evacuation operation and
that is a military operation and when
that neo takes place there's some really
clear things that happen this was not a
neo
so the state department was given
control of the operation and as soon as
the state department is given control
they run everything like an embassy
so think about every movie you've ever
seen where like the you know someone's
running to the embassy and once they get
in they're safe it's that kind of
thought process so it's like we'll take
responsibility of this little block of
space that we have the airport became
the embassy and then everything outside
of it was the host nation country i mean
it's literally like base when you're
playing
tag or whatever like make it to base and
you'll be fine yeah you don't los siento
mucho man yeah
wow isn't it almost like sometimes it
seems like the it's like well if we just
pretend it's not happening it won't
happen like what was the embassy take
over it was when carter was president
and uh it was somewhere in the middle
east there was an embassy takeover and
he just i think they weren't allowed to
fire on the people uh attacking the
embassy and it's almost like this weird
hope that if we just don't engage it
will stop and they'll go away on their
own i have a different approach to all
that you know
um
like
violence and strength and power like
they they if they only knew what the
marines in those embassies could do um
but they don't because they know their
hands are tied um you know just
occasionally just let them have a little
reminder of what it looks like when you
let that pit bull that's been starved in
a cage and just wants to get in fight
all the time yes out of the cage then
tear something apart twist the knife in
the other direction yeah right like we
can twist the knife yeah we can do this
too man do you want to see what these
marines can do like these guys are studs
because it does it does i guess
it
makes us look weak or uh i guess like
they said that one of the things that
motivated bin laden was seeing the
troops pull out of uh what was when
clinton pulled out those troops out of
uh i forget where they were but there
was a bunch got pulled out they said
they see a few american bodies they pull
all the troops out and they said that
kind of involved in bin laden was this
was afghanistan was that inevitable or
would there have been a way to get
troops out oh there's a they're really i
mean like you go back to like soon zoo
era about how to withdrawal troops you
know you've
done kirk there are lots of examples
about how to move off of a withdrawal
and how to remove yourself from um
occupying territory uh
nowhere in any playbook is it like do
you know what you do let's just give up
every crucial strategic piece of land to
the enemy um while we're doing this so
the way that you do it is you keep
strategic pieces of land while you fall
back to um
efficient effective places to move all
of your forces out while you maintain
the these strategic positions and then
you collapse and fall out instead it was
just like cool uh peace out
like that's wild yeah and uh you know
ukraine's like the opposite of this
where
yeah ultimately the people are still
screwed so save our allies um having to
go to ukraine like we rinse and repeated
the same logistical process of of
afghanistan but instead of getting
things out we're also getting things in
um and uh and then afghanistan was just
getting people out but it's it's kind of
the same
efficient logistics
in reverse now as guys who get [ __ ] done
when you hear something like this texas
shooting and everyone's calling the cops
cowards and they should have went in
um
what is your take on that like do you
think that they were just being afraid
or do you think that they were told not
to go in and wanted to go in but weren't
permitted i have lots of thoughts on
this uh i i've actually been spending
almost non-stop uh every time that i
haven't been working writing about uh
these active shooters
um it's a combination the police the
police are what we made them the police
are are the politically correct cow like
if we're gonna call them cowards and how
they behaved that's what we forced them
to become where we want them to not have
the initiative not to be um you know
kicking in doors to go and do things is
this hostage rescue is this an active
shooter we have two different policies
one for a hostage rescue they're not
allowed to go in unless we have specific
people in place if you go into a hostage
rescue situation at the right at the
wrong time the hostages will get
executed right so they thought this was
a hostage rescue situation so they
started in placing people waiting for
the right moment to go in and if trigger
happens where the hostage taker starts
executing hostages then they immediately
go in well there was confusion in the
way that the communication was happening
there was a system breakdown with the
dispatch all of these this litany of
excuses
but these are all responsive things like
we're talking like we have to make our
schools hard targets do we need to arm
teachers do we need to train cops
differently yes yes and yes but we also
need to go upstream to where the problem
is the origin of
what is what is unhealthy about these
young men that are going out and doing
these shootings what is this mental
health crisis where these these people
are going these these young men are
going and murdering children
like what has gone wrong with us
culturally and as a society where this
is now commonplace uh the book is out
today it's called scars and stripes it's
tim kennedy's story and i mean i just
both of you guys are fascinating
fascinating guys i think there's just so
much to draw from just because of all
the experiences that you've both had
that most of us would never come near
thank god our lives are very different
we could talk brilliant for about six
hours and we could each go i've never
done that
very different existence yeah that's
beautiful though i love being human man
i love different experiences yeah i can
go to tim kennedy.com uh to get the book
and everything
grab it we appreciate you guys you gotta
get out of here yeah i know you guys so
uh yeah yeah and thank you the rest of
you for having us we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye